Steve: Welcome everyone. I'd like to welcome
our speaker today, Ari Juels. Ari is the head
of RSA Laboratories which is part of EMC and
he's written a fiction book about a young
cryptographer who stumbles upon a plot involving
ancient cults and a lot of intrigue.
And a little background of Ari. He's actually
a, has a background in Latin literature and
mathematics and graduated as a Ph.D. from
Berkeley, and surprisingly his main character
is also a Ph.D. from Berkeley with a background
in classics.
So I'd like to just turn it over to Ari and
welcome him to speak about his book.
[applause]
Ari Juels: Thank you, Steve, and thanks to
all of you for coming today.
Many first time novelists support themselves
with day jobs and I'm no exception. As Steve
mentioned I work as the Chief Scientist of
RSA Labs, the research arm of RSA, a company
that some of you are probably familiar with.
My lab's research is on computer security
and cryptology, encryption and other techniques
for protecting computer systems.
So my day job is like that of many of you
in the audience. But I want to stress that
my novel isn't written for computer scientists.
It's written for readers; for ordinary readers.
So there's a tiny bit of math in the book,
but not very much and there are only two lines
of pseudo code in the entire novel.
I am going to talk to you a little bit about
computer security and cryptology because they
loom large into 'Tetraktys'. But of course
I'm not wearing my RSA labs hat and I'm not
gonna talk about research.
I'm gonna talk to you instead about a collision
of worlds between ideas in modern cryptology
and the vision of a philosopher in ancient
Greece.
At first glance, computer security and the
ancient world don't seem to have much to do
with one another. But by the end of this talk
I hope you'll see how these two worlds are
coming together and how in the light and heat
of that collision the adventure and mystery
story 'Tetraktys' was born.
Probably the first question for most of you
in the audience is, "What in blazes does the
word 'Tetraktys' mean?" And, and of course
I'll get to that.
I feel that book talks for fiction at least
are kind of a tricky proposition. When a bakery
wants you to buy a cake they give you a sample.
But a book isn't like a cake; one bite of
a cake tastes like the rest of the cake. But
one chapter in a book doesn't taste, as it
were, like all of the others.
So what I would like to do instead, is to
try to entice you with something more atmospheric.
Call it the aroma of the book.
I am going to read some sample passages, but
I'm gonna give you a good deal of background
for the story and a little bit of visual support
in the form of just a few slides.
I'm pretty sure I'm not the first novelist
to use Power Point and this may be a somewhat
dangerous thing, but I hope you'll bear with
me.
Okay. So our story begins with some strange
computer infiltrations. We're not talking
about vanilla hackers stealing credit card
numbers or about foreign powers spying on
corporations like the Aurora attacks that
you've been dealing with here at Google. It's
much stranger than that.
The book opens with a passage about an Assistant
Secretary of State named Helen Abel and she's
simply having a little problem with her calendar.
So let me read the first chapter to you. I've
truncated it a bit.
[pause]
"Helen Abel, Assistant Secretary of State
for European Affairs, looked gradually into
the distance from a 17th century chateau.
She visually traced the sandy avenue that
ran the access of the vast gardens. Beneath
her lay two garden beds embroidered with green
arabesques of faultless symmetry; low trimmed
hedges winding amid a soil of rich, reddish
brown. These great carpets led from the terrace
of the chateau to the center of the gardens
where circular fountains sent aloft a towering
plume of water. Beyond lawn stretched smooth
and green around basins in which rings of
jets gave forth aqueous crowns. Near the horizon,
the Grand Canal spread its thin mirror of
water under a tiny portico.
Still further in the distance, visible as
a notch in the trees, was yet another rectangular
lawn thrusting the strict ethic of geometry
into the surrounding forest up toward the
sky.
The only inhabitants of the garden were statues
disposed here and there in decorous solitude;
French ghosts of Roman copies of Greek originals;
gods and heroes, Diana, Venus, Jove and Apollo,
stone animated with the memory of motion.
She'd been leaning into the huge monitor on
her desk to immerse herself as thoroughly
as possible. She now tilted back into the
chair behind her smoky glass helm and looked
again at the screen. She really shouldn't
be spending so much time fussing with these
videos.
On vacation in France the previous week after
a Summit she'd fantasized about a woman, what
a woman of her status might have been centuries
ago. Not a senior bureaucrat, but a great
and noble lady. She'd looked at costumes,
jewelry, palaces and gardens and spent many
thousands of dollars on antiques and reproductions
in Paris.
She'd even bought an 18th Century tiara set
with diamonds and sapphires. While other tourists
were only able to look uncomprehendingly and
snap photos, she had beheld her own reflection
in the glass cases of the museum aptly superimposed
upon the jewels, dresses and other treasures
within.
But now it was back to work. She had a staff
meeting in an hour. She turned to the black
viper-like microphone rising from the pool
of glass that was her desk. 'Calendar' she
commanded.
The garden dissolved from the monitor giving
way to the page of a calendar scattered with
flags and icons, somewhat like a military
map. A warning message highlighted by a gaudy
red bar blinked at the top of the screen and
a window popped up: "Reminder missed appointment."
What appointment could she have missed? Had
she simply neglected to click on reminders
early in the week or did her admin screw up
again?
She spoke again in the direction of the viper.
"Go to missed appointment." The screen turned
a gray blur; a sound like pouring rain saturated
the speakers; the calendar software made page
turning noises with each traversed week; and
the weeks now whished stormily backwards.
In the corner the year was still displayed,
but the last digit dropped quickly, three,
two one, zero, nine, eight; the second digit
also moved backward though more slowly.
'Stop,' Secretary Abel shouted. The year stood
at 1965; the week was empty of meeting. 'Go
to missed appointment,' she repeated in annoyance.
Hand it to Microsoft that was one hell of
a bug or worse could it be a virus?
The furious patter of flipped pages resumed.
She watched the slowly receding decade digit,
1950s, 1940s, 1930s; the century was rounded
and then 1890s, 1880s, 1870s. 'Stop,' she
cried again, freezing the year at 1872.
'Christ,' she thought, 'maybe it was something
worse than a bug.' She spoke more loudly and
precisely, 'Go to missed appointment.' The
vertiginious backward sweep resumed.
This time she watched in bewildered passivity.
It had never occurred to her to wonder, 'how
far back do these calendars actually go?'
1830s, 1820s, 1780s, 1770s, 1760s; the noise
ceased abruptly and a page appearing, appeared
displaying the week of 10th June 1754 and
fixed itself on the screen.
A new message appeared, 'Missed appointment.
Should the Office Assistant schedule a new
one?' In fact several appointments over the
course of the week were marked as missed.
The latest of these on a Friday evening flashed.
She had enough French to read, 'Ball at the
residence of Monsieur deCarzeneau Saint-Germain-des-Pres.'
Saint-Germain-des-Pres was a station in the
Paris Metro, that she knew. She had no idea
who Monsieur deCarzeneau was.
She explored nearby entries on the calendar
looking for evidence of a bug in the software.
There were so many appointments that it seemed
as though somebody else's life had been accidentally
grafted into an unlikely part of her calendar.
'This was like finding a hidden passageway
in an old house,' she thought. 'Rather fun,
actually.'
It soon became clear why the ball along with
many other social engagements had been missed.
It appeared that the owner of this portion
of the calendar had become bedridden with
a long illness. The ministrations of a Doctor
Dachmoi and a Doctor Parre had began in April
of 1754. They'd progressed from regular to
frequent over the course of May. By the beginning
of June, these doctors were in constant attendance.
Had Secretary Abel's historical medical French
been richer she would have deciphered descriptions
of a vigorous regimen of cupping, bleedings,
and the administration of poisonous metals.
These medical rigors culminated on the 15th
of June when the patient had her last appointment
in the book. This was annotated 'la mort',
death. The 15th of June she observed was her
birthday. The fun took an unnerving turn.
She went further back; there were dozens of
trivial engagements which seemed vaguely but
impalpably to trigger memories. Then on the
18th of December 1730 there was Aunt Jean's
funeral. Could she remember the day, the weather?
Was the low hanging gray sky a post-dated
symbolic trick of memory?
Her sister to whom she hadn't spoken in three
years called to tell her that Aunt Jean was
dead. Two weeks later a lawyer hired by her
sister called to tell her that there was a
crazed boyfriend of sorts in the picture,
and she remembered her disgust at how the
word 'boyfriend' was used to describe the
80 year old man.
The lawyer was trying to pry the old woman's
legacy away from this interloper. The boyfriend
wanted to funnel it to a church.
Times had been difficult in these early days
when she was getting her Master's Degree.
The aunt had been a wealthy widow, a fragile
octogenarian.
Even while her aunt was living, she had never
been entirely successful fending off daydreams
of an inheritance. She almost never saw the
old woman who refused to leave the Bronx where
Helen herself certainly wasn't gonna go.
The aunt had sent fifty dollar checks in garish
greeting cards on Helen's birthday and on
holidays. Helen had always sent back dutiful
thank yous. She simply hadn't noticed that
nothing had come from Aunt Jean for a year
and a half.
Her sister having gone to clean out the apartment
and called her again. The old woman it turned
out had been a miser and a packrat and had
lived in squalor. The apartment was a morass
of burned out light bulbs, moldy wallpaper,
broken radiators, crumbling plaster, heaps
of old newspaper waiting to catch fire, mice
and tattered doilies, amid a miasma of dust,
furniture polish and urine.
Helen had felt unspeakably guilty and had
palliated her guilt by telling herself that
the old woman had never asked for her help.
The calendar, however, made a firmer accusation.
In a matter of fact way, like a reminder for
a lunch appointment, which it was, the entry
read, 'Poisoning of Aunt Jean.' 'No,' she
protested out loud. 'No, I know what that
means. That's a lie.' She shook her head.
'It wasn't my fault,' she said to herself.
'If she'd ever asked for help ever, I would
have helped her.'
She dug angrily deeper into the calendar.
What other accusations were there? She read
and reread the calendar entries trying to
ferret out all of the secret correspondences.
If a history of the grand dame matched her
own, then she had only two more years to live.
Her antecedent had died at the age of 49.
Her meeting was beginning in a matter of minutes.
Bewildered and exhausted and paying little
attention to what she was doing, she made
her way back to her own era.
Instead of keying the current date into the
computer, she held down the forward arrow
key with her index finger. The weeks advanced;
the years hastened by, 1750s, 1760s, 1770s,
1780s. She traversed the blank corridors devoid
of appointments of the late 18th, the 19th,
the early and mid-20th century. From Aunt
Jean's funeral and the balls, fetes and deaths,
back to her own epic.
Rounding her birthday in the year 1970 she
came upon the following entry: 'an. 1970 - an.
1754 = 215 = 63 hic incipit saeclum vitae
novum. [Here begins a new cycle of life.]
Reincarnate.'"
[sound of pages turning]
Attacks like this against Secretary Abel multiply
as the story gathers pace. There are strange
references to reincarnation, numerology, like
the game here with dates that Helen Abel came
across, and vegetarianism. The attacks become
so serious and widespread that the National
Security Agency gets involved. And what do
they find?
They trace the attacks to what seems to be
a cult of followers of the ancient philosopher
Pythagoras who was active in the sixth century
B.C. So you see a, a bust of him here.
Now we tend to think of Pythagoras as the
fellow who discovered the Pythagorean theorem
which, which in fact he probably didn't, but
you'll remember we learn about this theorem
in school; it's a theorem about right triangles.
You see it here; a2 + b2 = c2.
But Pythagoras was actually much, much more
than just a small torment to junior high school
students. He really was a philosopher in the
broadest sense of the word. And in fact he's
even credited with coining the very word "philosophy."
He and his followers created one of the earliest
notions of a political utopia and actually
seized control of a city in southern Italy
to try to realize this, this vision.
But getting back to mathematics. It was a
very strange affair in Pythagoras' day. It
was in many ways more like sorcery than science.
We don't have a terribly accurate picture
of what Pythagoras and his followers were
like, but in some ways they weren't all that
different from the people you might come across
say across the Bay in Berkeley.
For instance, they were probably vegetarian;
they believed in reincarnation. In fact they
believed in transmigration of souls; this
idea that you might die and wake up a cow
or a house cat. And they wore unusual clothing.
Pythagoras, for instance, wore a white robe
and a gold diadem. And Pythagoras himself
may actually have claimed to be an incarnation
of the god Apollo.
They had other habits we can't begin to understand
and probably never will. Some of their maxims
have come down to us. Some are sensible, like
for instance, one of their maxims was "Eat
not in the chariot." In other words, don't
eat while you're driving. Others are just
weird and foreign, particularly if you're
vegetarian, like keep away from the vinegar
bottle; an inscrutable one that.
They considered it a crime to throw stones
into fountains and they said, "No matter you
do, don't ever, ever catch a cuttlefish."
Really strange stuff.
But one thing they believed in makes them
a lot like us, given how our world is pervaded
by computing. In particular, they believed
above all in the primacy of number. They believed
that numbers were the fabric of the universe
and they believed this in a way that resonates
particularly well in our digital world.
[pause]
So this idea about the supremacy of number
was encapsulated in a sacred symbol for the
Pythagoreans called the Tetraktys; you see
it up here.
The tetra part as you may have guessed means
four. There's really no good translation for
the full word 'Tetraktys', perhaps the best
translation is something like the essence
of fourness.
Anyway you see it's a pyramid of ten dots
aligned in four rows. This one symbol for
the Pythagoreans embodied the foundations
of the universe.
So let's start with music, for instance. We
number the rows as here. And now look at the
ratios that those numberings define; the three
different ratios defined by the Tetraktys.
Well, let's start with a ratio 1:2. If you
take a string and pluck it; let's suppose
it produces the note C; and then you take
that string and you exactly double its length,
you'll again get the note C, only it will
be one octave lower. So the ratio 1:2 in the
Tetraktys defines the octave.
Similarly the ratio 2:3 defines the interval
of a fifth; roughly speaking that's a span
of five keys on the piano. And 3:4 defines
an interval of a fourth; roughly a span of
four keys on the piano. That's in a, a differently
tempered world but I won't get into that.
So with this reasoning the Tetraktys encapsulated
the basics of, of music and consequently the
idea of the harmony of the spheres; the resonant
substance of the cosmos, the universe.
The Tetraktys also encapsulates the basics
of geometry and I'll just go through this
very quickly.
The first row is, is a point; zero dimensions.
The second row contains two dots; you connect
them you get a line; that's one dimension.
The third row contains three, they form a
triangle; two dimensions. And the fourth contains
four dots; if you connect them up like this
you get a pyramid; three dimensions.
So all of the known dimensions of our universe,
the ones that we experience at any rate, are
encapsulated in the Tetraktys. So you can
think of the Tetraktys as being a little like
our periodic chart in chemistry or perhaps
even a little like string theory, only much
cruder and, and much more powerful.
[pause]
So the Pythagoreans are the villains in our
story, if they really are villains, which
isn't at all clear. Now of course the National
Security Agency isn't accustomed to dealing
with incarnations of the god Apollo, so they
bring in an un, unusual young man named Ambrose
Jerusalem.
Ambrose is finishing up his doctorate in computer
science just across the Bay in, in Berkeley,
but he's unusual in that he was home schooled
by his father, a classical archeologist. A
really intense guy who would even taste the
dirt and artifacts to make sure that they
were authentic.
Ambrose is exactly what the NSA needs because
he straddles these two worlds; the worlds
of computer science and antiquity.
To give you a sense of what Ambrose is like,
I'm gonna read another passage. This is a
passage in which Ambrose has been approached
by the NSA, and he's remembering the things
that his father told him when he was a child;
the things about Pythagoras in particular.
And again I've truncated the, the chapter
somewhat here.
[pause]
[sound of pages turning]
"Outside of the two crowded tourist seasons—midsummer,
and a space of two weeks around the peak of
the fall foliage—Dorington was a picture-book
specimen of rural New England. Even as natives
of the region, if not the town, Dr. Jerusalem
and his nine-year-old son felt a sense, a
heightened sense of charm as they walked a
dirt road away from the town center. The town
consisted of a clutch of white, wooden buildings:
a clapboard post office, a general store,
and a patterned New England church with a
single steeple atop a square base. (Savoring
the irony, Dr. Jerusalem pointed out that
such churches were modeled on the architectural
template of an English Catholic.)
The ground was still sodden in late afternoon.
The trees turned forth cold, luxuriant greenery
touched here and there with hints of autumn.
Ambrose’s photojournalist’s vest—his
favorite piece of clothing, with the pockets
of the many treasures—was just warm enough.
The bleak weather seemed to embalm the isolated
houses in a way that brought a cozy pleasure
to him. There could be no vain scrambling
to find one’s destiny, here. It lay not
more than five feet from the fireplace, as
in ancient years. His father frequently set
Ambrose ruminating on civilizations tens of
centuries old, on the frenetically unfolding,
spreading, and splintering empires of the
Mediterranean. Several times together they
had visited archaeological sites. Now, as
then Ambrose ran his mind over the traces
of antiquity. The jewelweed and blank yellow
and copper leaves scattered on the forest
floor, the broken stone walls and raw timber
of old buildings evoked, if they did not resemble,
the altars and groves of ancient Greece or
Italy.
They approached the edge of a pasture enclosed
in wire, in which horses grazed. Dr. Jerusalem
bounced the back of his hand on the top wire,
the ends of which stretched between white
plastic cylinders on wooden posts. 'Not electrified,'
he said. A dappled gray horse came over to
them, and Dr. Jerusalem stroked it under the
forelock. The animal awkwardly tilted its
head up and down, as if unsure how to nod
approval and enjoy the scratching at the same
time. Dr. Jerusalem encouraged Ambrose to
pat the horse’s head.
Ambrose said, 'It's an intelligent horse.'
'Yes she is. A beautiful mare,' his father
replied stroking her head. 'There's soul in
those eyes.'
'Maybe there's a person trapped in the horse
like in the story I read by Apuleius. He was
turned into an ass though. That's like a donkey.'
Dr. Jerusalem laughed, 'Yes, so maybe this
is some Russian empress who according to the
great wheels of cosmic justice was reincarnated
as a mare.' He chuckled at his private joke.
'Reminds me of Xenophanes' story about Pythagoras
and the dog. Have I ever told it to you?'
'I don't think so,' Ambrose said seriously.
'Pythagoras was the ancient philosopher who
coined the word "philosophy." He also invented—or
at least popularized—the Pythagorean Theorem.
Yes, I know you know that already. Well, the
Pythagoreans thought of numbers a little like
we might think of gods. Pythagoras himself
was a bit of a loon.'
'How?' Ambrose asked in surprise.
'Well, one story goes like this: He was walking
down the street in Kroton—in southern Italy—one
day, when he saw a man kicking a dog. Normally,
this wouldn’t have bothered anyone in the
ancient Greek world. But Pythagoras was different.
"Stop," he shouted at the rogue. "Stop that
at once! This dog is a friend!" Pythagoras
explained that the dog was a reincarnated
friend from a previous life. He recognized
him by his bark.'
'Did he take the dog home?'
'A very good question. But that’s the whole
story. My guess is that Pythagoras had probably
collected too many friends at home as it was,
and I doubt his wife appreciated it—although
Theano herself was also a formidable philosopher.
I’m sure the dog kicker was stunned, and
left his dog alone for at least a few days.'
'How cruel!' said Ambrose. 'Pythagoras should
have taken the dog home with him. Is that
why he didn't eat animals?'
'You mean why he was vegetarian?'
'Yes.'
'That may be a myth. But almost everything
about Pythagoras is a myth, Ambrose. All we
know with anything approaching certainty is
that he was some kind of genius—and that
he abstained from eating beans and ox hearts.
It’s not impossible that he was a vegetarian,
though.'
Father and son fell silent. An old pickup
truck with a wood-railed cargo space drove
by, forcing Ambrose and his father to the
edge of the road. Damp, colored leaves glistened
on the forest floor like the shiny coat of
an exotic, broad-backed creature. Ambrose
mused, 'I wonder whether I’d remember if
I’d been a horse in another life.'
'Do you?' Dr. Jerusalem asked. 'What would
you remember?'
'I don't know. Maybe my pasture. And people
petting me. And how hay tastes.'
'I've raised a confirmed Pythagorean then.
Do you know the Pythagoreans tried more or
less just that?'
'What do you mean?'
'They used to perform exercises to improve
their memories. Every evening, Ambrose, they
would try to recall all of the events that
had occurred over the course of the day. Imagine
it. They’d try to recollect finer and finer
details: faces, clothing, what they ate, whom
they saw. A word that a friend deftly pulled
out of a hat in a conversation on philosophic
doctrine in the morning. An odor that wafted
with the midday breeze near the western entrance
to the agora. Variations in the shapes of
the clouds during the afternoon before a storm
broke. How the texture of their tunics felt
from hour to hour. Then they’d try to extend
their recollections to more and more distant
times: previous days, weeks, and years. They
hoped, eventually—they claimed in certain
cases, as Pythagoras did—to recall events
from former lives.'
Again they walked for a long time in silence.
The sun set and the sky began to glow. Ambrose
tried forcing on himself a consciousness of
the texture of his clothing. He attuned himself
to the places where it touched, brushed, or
lay lightly on his skin. He felt his stomach
rumble. As he turned his attention upward
to the orange evening sky, he felt a ghostly
attraction to the place—or rather, its tutelary
spirit—a desire to embrace it, to sleep
by its side. He didn’t know what this meant,
and he could not articulate it. He could only
experience the bagful of sensations and submit
to a feeling that was too grand and tenuous,
predicated too glimmeringly on a slant of
light, for him to possess.
He felt as if his father would glibly discouraging
something important. But he had no way to
protest.
'So do you think the feelings are lies? Are
they bad?'
'No, not bad, Ambrose. Quite the opposite.
They're too important to be badly handled.
The successors to the Pythagoreans went wrong.
They tried to reduce them to a superstitious
system, to explain these poetic and highly
individual experiences in terms of a simplistic
universal, like reincarnation or numbers.
I can’t prove it, but the original Pythagoreans
to my mind clearly believed in living in the
world. Memory—historical, personal—of
course it's the substance of life. Without
that depth of perception, we’re Cyclopes,
one-eyed monsters. But today we replace our
human memories with computer memories, with
exomemories and exominds. That spells the
death of nostalgia, the loosening of the deep
cord with which an ancient ruin or this spot
of countryside resonates in you, Ambrose.
Recall that "memory" in Greek was the mother
of the muses.'
'I know.'
'The world is placing less and less value
on such things. Fewer and fewer people with
memory these days. Memory has been shunted
off to a nursing home. The muses will follow
soon. I have you learn poetry by heart to
nourish your spirit and your mind—to glue
it to your soul, Ambrose. That’s just one
reason I’m educating you yourself. Do you
understand?'
'I think so.'
'Do you know the famous poem by Frost about
the two paths that "diverged in a yellow wood"?
The Pythagoreans called it the Furca Pythagorica,
the Pythagorean Fork. They represented it
by the letter upsilon. Upsilon resembles our
capital letter Y, right? It’s forked. You
will face the Furca Pythagorica many times
in your life, Ambrose. I’ve led you down
a different branch of the fork than nearly
anyone else will follow.'
Ambrose looked at the road behind them which
lay straight as far as the eye could see.
He held up two fingers as though in a sign
of victory.
'What happened to them?' he asked. 'To the
Pythagoreans? They chose the wrong branch?'
'The Pythagoreans were the original utopians,
Ambrose. Bringers of the gods’ fire to Earth,
if you will. The first aristocrats in the
true sense of the word. I don’t mean lazy
snobs from privileged families with a ‘de’
or ‘von’ in their names. Just the opposite.
I mean that they tried to create a community
of aristoi, the ‘best’—noble, wise,
elect guardians of civilization. It was too
much. Most of Pythagoras’s followers couldn’t
understand. Pythagoras had unearthly mental
gifts and vision. He was strange; he was godlike.
Some of his early followers forgot what they
learned. Plato, Augustine, More, Jefferson—they
all owed a debt to Pythagoras. They remembered
some of the important teachings. But too many
have forgotten.'
Dr. Jerusalem stopped and put his hand on
Ambrose’s shoulder. 'I sometimes lose sight
of how young you are. But this is one of the
burdens I'll have to place on your shoulders.
We’ll make sure that you don’t forget
entirely. You’ll be rooted in other times
and places. It 's the only way to understand
your own. You’ll be one of the last with
the gift of a classically educated mind, Ambrose.
The barbarians are again sweeping over the
land, and it’s time to retreat to Hibernia—to
bide our time across the sea. Perhaps the
aristoi will come again. But perhaps you’ll
be alone.'
[pause]
[sound of pages turning]
Now where does the mathematical view of the
Pythagoreans come together with modern cryptology?
In other words, why is Ambrose at the right
intersection of ideas?
The NSA believes that the cult of Pythagoreans
has used its mathematical prowess to break
a cryptographic algorithm known as RSA; many
of you are probably familiar with it. Named
after its inventors at MIT in 1977, Rivest,
Shamir and Adleman. Here's a picture dating
from that decade obviously. Some of you will
see a nice little joke on the blackboard there.
Most of you in this audience probably know
that RSA is a real algorithm used in nearly
every computing system in the world today.
It operates, for instance, when you send your
credit card information over the Internet
and a little lock appears in the corner of
your browser, as, as here.
So breaking RSA would compromise computing
systems in a devastating way. It would basically
undermine the whole trust infrastructure of
the Internet. In fact at this very moment
about a mile away at the Moscone Center, the
RSA Conference is taking place. This is a
huge industry conference staged every year
by the company RSA, and Rivest, Shamir and
Adleman are probably there at this, this very
moment.
Now you see here the basic formula; one of
them for RSA m = cd mod pq. It looks a little
like
e=mc2, right? It's got the same sort of simplicity
and, and elegance.
Now the Pythagoreans believed in the power
of a very particular type of mathematics,
based on integers. And closest in spirit to
what we would call number theory today. Mathematicians
who specialized in this area used to pride
themselves on studying the most useless form
of math. They believed that their discipline
enjoyed a kind of peerless intellectual purity.
We know that calculus is useful, but they
asked themselves, "What possible use could
there be for things like prime numbers?"
Well Pythagorean ideas about numbers and their
supremacy; all this numerological gobblygook
seems little silly at first blush, but Pythagoreans
were even writing prayers to numbers like
their Tetraktys. But the earth shook under
the feet of those number theorists a few decades
ago. Prime numbers suddenly found a use; protecting
secrets, cryptology.
So these number theorists found themselves
whisked away from their ivory towers into
the fortress of the NSA.
Now Ambrose realizes that as computing gravitates
toward the center of our universe and cryptography
spreads, the whole Pythagorean idea of prowess
in number theory, of secrecy and so forth,
doesn't seem so far off base any longer. Pythagoras
said famously that the universe is number
and he meant it in a mystical way. Well cryptology
directly links the knowledge of numbers with
the unraveling of secrets and control of what
we might even think of as divine forces, in
a loose sense. So it gives body to the mysticism.
[pause]
As many of you know, to break the RSA algorithm
all you have to do is solve the following
very simple problem. I randomly picked two
numbers, call them P and Q. I generate them
behind my back and I multiply them behind
my back. Now these are prime numbers; they're
divisible only by themselves and one, as,
as many of you know.
So we'll call the product of these two integers
N. So now what I do is I give you N and your
task is to figure out the original P and Q,
as it were to split this number N.
When P and Q are very big, and so therefore
when N is very big, this problem is believed
to be very hard; and by big I mean really
big. Here's, here's an example of what N might
look like in the real world.
So this is the cornerstone of the RSA algorithm;
this problem of factoring as it's called.
And this is the problem that the NSA thinks
that the Pythagoreans have solved in order
to crack the RSA algorithm.
As the story gathers pace, messages like the
one that Secretary Abel came across multiplied.
Other powerful people start to be menaced.
So how do Ambrose and the NSA sleuth out the
identities of the Pythagoreans? They use a
number of techniques: there's classical scholarship;
there's gumshoe sleuthing; and computer forensics
also come into play.
So let me read a last bit from the book. This,
this bit needs a little bit of explanation.
The messages left by the Pythagoreans like
the one left for Secretary Abel have been
essentially flawless, but Ambrose and the
NSA noticed a typo in one of them. In one
message the word "Syracuse," like the name
of the town in upstate New York, which is
also the name of an, a city in the ancient
world, Greek city, is misspelled. Somehow
the letter "e" dropped off the end and they
ended up with Syracus instead of Syracuse.
It's a tiny, tiny clue, but it turns out to
be critical.
So in this passage there's a conversation
taking place between Ambrose and Rochelle
his supervisor at the NSA.
[pause]
[sound of pages turning]
"Ambrose prepared another list of books and
they again sent out to the library. In the
meantime he read about the history of Huron
and the City of Syracuse extracting what he
could from the reference books on hand. Rochelle
searched the Web to learn some rudiments.
'Look here. I found a portrait,' she announced,
swiveling her monitor to show Ambrose photographs
of the two sides of a silver coin on auction.
The reverse depicted a galloping cavalryman
carrying a sphere. The obverse showed a beardless
man in profile with a prominent round chin
and a small ear; his curly mass of hair bound
in a slender band tied from behind.
'He looks young for a king.'
'That's thanks to Alexander the Great. He
started the vogue in boyish looks for conquerors.'
'Apart from that,' Rochelle said, 'every Website
has the same historical snippet on Huron.
Nothing more than you told me. Any luck on
your end?'
'No. Not yet.'
'Really, Ambrose. Are we chasing our tails?
Can one letter really mean all that much anyway?
Syracuse, Syracus. Is it really such a big
deal? Couldn't it just be a spelling error
or a typo?'
'It could be a typo. In that case it may not
mean much, but every other piece of writing
we've seen from the neo-Pythagoreans or that
I have at least, has been more or less flawless.'
'True. But a typo?'
'That doesn't answer your question, does it?'
'Can a single letter be important?'
'Yes, absolutely.'
'There's a town in northern Italy called Cortona.
Ancient tradition asserts that the tomb of
Pythagoras lies there. But Pythagoras probably
never visited northern Italy. It was a mistake.
Somebody confused Cortona with Cratona, the
Latin name for the City of Crotone in southern
Italy.'
'In classical literature these little errors
are everything. For example, the original
name of the author The Aeneid was Vergil,
that's spelled v-e, but then in the Middle
Ages when he was believed to be a magician
of some kind, it became Virgil, v-i. You can
tell a Brit from an American by his spelling.
For instance, the Brit spells it v-e, while
the American spells it v-i.
Where it gets especially interesting is in
Medieval manuscripts. Everyone has spelling
errors and they're like differences in DNA;
they mark time and pedigree and they allow
philologists to date manuscripts and place
them at a kind of family tree.'
'So you're hoping that this missing "e" may
be our key DNA marker? Was Syracuse every
spelled Syracus by the Greeks?'
'No. I've looked it up in Little and Scott.
There were several variance on the name in
Greek, the Ionian Syracusi,' Ambrose said.
He continued, 'And also the Doric and others.
I'm pretty sure that Syracus is the modern
German spelling, but I just can't see any
reason for writing Syracus in English.'
'I see. So to put it in your terms, the word
Syracus is a mutation of some kind.'
'Well, yes,' Ambrose replied. 'I suppose you
could say that.'
'But that makes it distinctive, you see?'"
[pause]
The NSA ends up plunging into various types
of computer forensics to figure all of this
out and actually a remarkable thing happened
while I was writing this story. I was making
up certain forensic techniques in Tetraktys
to track down the Pythagoreans as it were,
when this patent suddenly surfaced describing
exactly the techniques I was developing in
this fictional context. Only I hadn't filed
that patent; it was the NSA. So it's just
one of these wonderful coincidences I guess
I, I happened to, to divine what the, what
the NSA was up to as I was writing this story.
As the story evolves, the Pythagoreans gradually
infiltrate many parts of the world online
and off. Lottery numbers get changed; airline
schedules are modified; and some great event
seems to be coming to a head.
But it's not clear whether the Pythagoreans
are a malevolent or benign force. After all
these are the people who tried to establish
Utopia many years ago; the bringing a certain
beauty to the world and reviving classical
ideals.
Ambrose as you can imagine with his background,
has a yearning for these things. So he has
to grapple with what's real and what's not.
And whether he may be working for the NSA
to try to hunt down and destroy a group that
may be older and wiser than we are and could
bring a certain order and moral force to the
world.
So who are these Pythagoreans and how do they
break the RSA algorithm? And what does ancient
Greece tell us about our own evolving digital
world and authenticity?
These, these are the questions at the heart
of 'Tetraktys'.
So I hope that after hearing me speak today,
you'll accept my invitation to join Ambrose
on his, on his journey and explore the mystery.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Steve: If you have questions, please use the
mic in the middle of the room.
[pause]
male voice in audience: This is a somewhat
standard question for people who have very,
very busy schedules and pretty big day jobs.
How were you able to carve out time to, to
welcome your muse?
Ari Juels: That's a, that's a great question.
So the first answer is that it took me over
10 years to write the book.
The second answer is that to some extent I
don't remember and I often wonder in fact
if I just happened to encounter some genie;
picked up a bottle on the beach or something
and made a deal. I said "Okay, you can erase
10 years of my life if a book will just pop
out." And, and that happened. Because I really
don't have a strong recollection of how on
earth I squeezed my writing time in.
[pause]
male voice in audience: In your book you reference
the NSA and the interactions there and in
the panel you'd chaired earlier this week
at the RSA conference. There's a really interesting
cultural contrast between the representative
from the NSA and the other members of the
panel.
How does that, what is your characterization
of the NSA culture and how does that play
out in terms of the book? Is that, is that
a part of the book or is that really secondary?
Ari Juels: Well, I don't have intimate knowledge
of the culture of the NSA, of course very
few people outside the NSA do. So to some
extent I, I had to try to make guesses. As
I mentioned, I made at least one happy technical
guess. I don't know whether the cultural guesses
that I made were accurate.
Some of the elements of the book are, are
certainly farfetched, but there, there certainly
is a sharp difference between the academic
perspective and the, and the NSA perspective.
And I think the little that I know has probably
percolated into the book, but I'm not sure
I can give you a crisp characterization.
[pause]
female voice in audience: Thank you, Ari.
Ari Juels: Okay. Thank you very much.
[applause]